A huge debacle at a zoo in the tiny country
of Denmark has managed to overshadow even the Sochi Olympic screw ups.
[MUSIC]
Hey humans, Trace here for DNews -- Zookeepers
at the Copenhagen Zoo killed an 18-month-old
reticulated giraffe this weekend. Marius the
giraffe was an inbred QUOTE "surplus" animal
who would never have been allowed to breed
in captivity -- because his genes were already
overrepresented in the captive population.
Their solution was to let him live for a little
while, and then euthanize him. Once killed,
the zookeepers demonstrated how they would
carve the meat for use in the zoo, and then
fed it to the lions. The world outside of
Denmark, however, sort of... exploded. There
were protests, death threats and terrible
responses. There were offers to adopt Marius,
who in-spite of being inbred, was a healthy
male. However, that's actually AGAINST ZOO
RULES! The European Association of Zoos and
Aquariums said in a statement today they "fully
support the decision of the zoo to humanely
put the animal down." And the Association
of Zoos and Aquariums here in the United States
also stresses they value a QUOTE "healthy,
genetically diverse, and demographically varied
population." In order to be an accredited
AZA or EAZA member, zoos have to abide by
each organization's rules. In the US, there
are 22 sections to the animal disposition
section of the AZA Species Survival Plan.
And in there, it says specifically euthanasia
is one appropriate action.
EAZA regulations specify young animals who
are unable to go to better facilities and
will not provide for the genetic future of
the species should be euthanised. It's rare,
but it happens. AZA regulations go so far
as to limit the donation of zoo animals to
private owners too! Rather than robbing a
better genetic specimen from the limited spots
available in the zoos of the world, the zookeepers
made a very difficult decision.
Arguably, the zookeepers chose to turn this
part of the life cycle of a wild animal into
a demonstration -- which some would call a
spectacle. And that in itself might be the
cause of the vitriol, but as the zookeepers
see it, the problem isn't the death of Marius
the giraffe, but the overblown negative response.
Death threats for this? Really?
In their statement, the EAZA said, "More than
7000 people attended Copenhagen Zoo yesterday
and left far better informed about wildlife
than when they entered, including the real
threats to the future of giraffes."
Did the Danish zookeepers and the EAZA do
the right thing for the survival of the species?
One expert told PhysOrg they felt the Disneyfication
of animals has led people to forget ALL animals
are FOOD for their predators. The giraffe
meat was fed to the lions, because they are
one of the only animals which would kill and
eat an adult giraffe in the wild, and it showed
interested zoo patrons a glimpse into the
the real-life Lion King.
How do you feel about how the Copenhagen zookeepers
handled this? Share your feelings below and
subscribe for more DNews, every day.